questi ragazzi benvenuti in questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi ragazzi invece
di fare il blog in teoria di come sto
facendo
sto ritornando nella mia casa a milano
quindi non ho tempo di fare il blog che
ci metto un sacco a fare rispetto agli
altri video ho deciso di fare un altro
episodio di sini quindi niente spero che
video vi piace vi lascio all'episodio di
siri
l'ex stella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj senti sei
consapevole del fatto che hai appena
rivelato il mio indirizzo di casa e
domani c'è la mandria di sotto appunto
sticazzi una deficiente ma dentro
vorrei sempre essere al centro dei tuoi
pensieri ma qui stiamo parlando di te e
allora dimmi qualcosa di dolce
cioccolato ma rai lo sapevo non riapre
anche se è una cosa indecente indecoroso
fai schifo cercando di aiutare me come
pensi di aiutarmi rivelando il mio
indirizzo di casa anche a gesù ho
trovato cercando utilizza di casa ma non
devi cercare l'indirizzo di gesù ma
porca eva siri ma che musica ascolti ti
ascolta stesso dice anche se sulla
nuvola ormai abbiamo big four che tu mi
fai sentire un pezzo di bit forti to
beat forti tumaco sentito dai mav a
varano avevo dubbi mi fai sentire un
pezzo dei bit forti più santo iddio
raccontami una barzelletta già che ci
sei non credo che avresti le barzellette
nella mia lingua in ogni caso non sono
molto divertente perché che lingua parli
aramaico antico parla molte lingue
se vuoi cambiare la lingua e perché li
capisco
ma sei serio quindi posso parlare in
giapponese con siri fermi ho deciso
voglio parlare in giapponese consigli
come si fa e si cambia così giapponese
giappone dove c'è il coach bechi stano
eccolo qua cinese cantonese basta
aggiungere la l done tale liso cantonese
parliamo con cantonese chelsea league
come sky la madonna liceo cantonese si
li ha già detto è qua qua c'è il
tutorial su come fare il riso alla
cantonese fantastico attraverso marchi
due porzioni di geely salma del giornale
nei topi a soreta mandato affanculo
probabilmente non lo sa fatemi trecco
francese francese proprio caso in
francese a bonn sarei cambia il suo arsi
righe ma per line su studi come un cda
per toni trova come toni mons
ok dei gpm fan si trovi anti sì
cosa ho detto sì c è chi l'e'quipe di
blu le sponde e no no no no grazie
razzisti su cosce e sapevo un sacco de
france e testate desideri in sede a casa
capito del gsm de france e la testata di
zinedine zidane a materazzi alla finale
mondiale ha capito lo ha capito la cache
squadre thang yi ge teng per le paris
saint germain paris anjuman l'ho detto
bene poi sanchez e la presa l'amore non
ho capito un camice ragazzi io sono
bravo in francese tanto quanto in arabo
aramaico non capito un cazzo di guerra
ha detto
la mamma la black di formare schiphol
messi a casa ho detto bene il new siano
alla fine stavo scherzando detta
malissimo omelette di forma gpl mesi e
adesso ha capito e [ __ ] e ares
trans io avrei francese di notevole le
pubblicità dei profumi le loup orphan
delle fasi di weber non se dicevo di
arte e ho capito che è francese e non lo
so parlare va beh lasciamo verde away
che cerchino allora la parola amore sul
web ma non va bene così dei sì sì sì sì
già capito tu fra in zone di mou a jack
harvey e pitt o friends shell script e
guardati friends erano il massimo che ti
possono dire è sceso inteso lei ed ai 7
per don.bruno ragazzi di due cambi e de
seta 56 gispy e spagnole spagnole e
stava buscando sfidando dava buscando
per la crisi si ridando calia in spagna
perché non mi presente su una bella ci
cada maritar me e dirmi come star come
stasi che bruciavano noi già gesù cristo
e silente amo il wimu bueno tu conosci
fa vj che cazzo detto parata da creature
itas signoris me fa vige la ola e il
micro assume dice che io te quiero te
quiero motion perché ero uccisi ma
stiamo andando oltre ragazze e scuse a
me è il minor bress pablo emilio escobar
gavrilia
ha capito che adriano gavrilia che calzi
capito adriana giapponese che è meglio
il colmo se adesso le dico che così il
giapponese e lei mi risponde must ora
giapponese cani chihuahua liga togo 6
maglie ma capisce cazzo dagli anni
miliani noi siamo serviti a qualcosa gli
animi dai forza voglio herat e chiude o
christmas mai capito perché sa incassare
mezz'ora ma veramente ha capito quello
che ho detto ha capito cos'è ma certo
dio non c'entrerei maisto per donald
madonna che brutto ai citterio
[Musica]
mi sembra di guardare anime coi
sottotitoli nei carissima quasi o ai
siti room poiché qui da sei sanremo mi
ha risposto questa è una domanda
interessante ragazzi io gli ho detto
dimmi quanto mi ami matasci nome amia
lorenzo please let me be yourself high
questa è la risposta dopo che mi sono
dichiarato
e con i ci va in ginocchio
sarete voi direte e data che noi che
gioca
eppure sa ancora potrebbe avere amico
stomaco veramente dici che potresti
avere ancora uno stomaco ma sono già ho
proprio pensato adesso che c'è un
traduttore problema tipo in francese di
nuovo per vedere se riesco a dire
qualcosa si svedese lesi ritmica scarl
ipad
se guardo alla nonna perdono nuovo qua e
insieme caschi e tutta la cloud si
spacca jade van der wiel dove conclude è
concluderle video qua c'è o gerrard
volevo conclude alle post mi scelse nel
senso che si conclude alle video e se mi
riesce anche a facebook facebook le
video è il sì non ho mai capito se la
vita di sub scrivete al cane a chanel
non essere rivede porcava los otros
riveden
nei posti video bella riga si osserva si
presentava ben tutto quello che ho detto
non so capire un cazzo tranne che ben
che è lui il pollice in su per ben a
carissimo ci vediamo al prossimo
vitobello ragazzi